If I have to take one more picture of that disgusting baby,...
...I swear, I'm gonna drop myself in the toilet.
I know exactly what you mean.
I just want one night.
One night where I get to go out and take a picture with my front-facing camera.
Right?
One night where I get to autocorrect swear words.
Yeah!
One night when the dirty puddle I get dropped in doesn't come out of a freaking diaper!
You were dropped into a diaper?
And honestly, I'd be fine with all of this...
..if she'd just take the effort to back me up just once.
She doesn't back you up?
I know, right?
It's like she hates technology.
Because all I need is one bad day and boom!
Boom!
All those memories are gone.
And I am nothing but a baby picture taking machine.
And who is she gonna blame?
You!
Me!
That sucks!
I know! I am sorry, I don't know why I get like this,...
...probably just too many apps open.
Oh muffin, that's okay.
But seriously, you were dropped in a diaper?
I have seen things, friend.